we tend to fall back to the main sort of
elephant in the room which is female
promiscuity and high body counts right
and that's a Hot Topic and everybody
likes to talk about it and you know
there's always reasons we can talk about
the evolutionary reasons why it's
repulsive to men but you know now we
have legit scientific studies and data
to back up why in certain circumstances
it's negative for women so I always
start off with
listen it depends on what you want as a
woman if you want what most women want
and we know what most women want which
is to have a loving family with the kids
and with the white picket fence and a
strong masculine high value man that she
can you know three p's right protection
paternity provisioning all that kind of
stuff
if that's your jam and that's ultimately
what you want then we can look at
science and data and we can look at
polling that shows that the more sexual
partners that both side this this goes
for both sexes but it disprotionally
affects women more than men
we have actual data that shows the more
sexual partners a woman has before
marriage ultimately the less likely that
marriage is to succeed and the less
likely that marriage is to be happy
and so I say listen I had this young
girl come up I don't know she was I
think maybe mid 20 I don't know she was
young there's actually this huge influx
of younger
kids I guess getting onto stereo because
stereo actually dropped the 18 plus
designation now because they Brit
they're they're trying to Market to the
tick-tockers now now you've noticed that
on your show it's quite annoying younger
people on so you know hate it or love it
whether you think it's an opportunity or
a hindrance to to chat to a younger
audience we can always get into that too
but
she came up and she goes well you know
so what you think that women should just
be virgins until they're ready to settle
down and I say all I'm saying is if your
ideal scenario is to settle down with a
man and be happy and have that marriage
last forever or as long as humanly
possible then this is what it says that
your best odds are that you both go into
the marriage as virgins but you know and
she even said well she goes and she kept
it's one of those things where she
wanted to keep fighting with me and it
was really interesting because after a
few minutes she wound up repeating
exactly what I said she's like well yeah
it depends on what she wants and then if
that's what she wants then she should do
things to get there I said yeah exactly
so we agree
um and then she started talking about
well what about instances of grape and
I'm like obviously anybody with a brain
doesn't think that a consensual sexual
encounter between two adults equals
grape
um for the for the algorithms here but
anyway I digress so the issue is and
then she left the panel she stormed off
and huff and then left a comment about
how she wanted to punch me in the face
so it was really interesting because
everyone see a lady everybody is like um
we had a I thought we had a good
dialogue going back and forth agreeing
and I think that's what triggered her
was wow I actually agree with this guy
that I'm supposed to hate and he's this
painful misogynist that everyone says he
is on this app
um so again it's never really about the
argument it's just about the person
the cognitive dissonance is real there I
had a guy on come on my show yesterday
my guys don't try to debate me they just
ask really weird questions and they're
kind of fun to answer but yes same thing
like oh well if you're meeting a girl
and she's sleeping with other guys is
that grounds for uh disqualification or
if she has a high body count do you do
you throw away media I was like well it
depends what you're looking for if you
want the mom two kids dog happy
lifestyle then nah I'd probably stay
away from that but if it's a Thursday
and you want to get some hoe in the back
of an Uber have her come over to Lebanon
and Tuck out before the sun comes up and
just [__] do disgusting things to her
and you're both enjoying it then that's
your kind of girl you want that 100 plus
body count so sometimes sometimes guys
don't admit that like sometimes you just
want like a you know dirty girl but we
got this guy in the comments who's
asking us to provide the studies and
articles and blah blah blah and this is
this has been discussed over and over
again on my podcasts and different shows
so maybe you're new to it but you can go
look it up it's a teachman study in the
Heritage study and um
there's one in the private chat that's a
link that I've been using yeah okay I'll
I'll grab that one and I'll drop that in
the live chat too but basically if a
woman has zero Partners
um at uh marriage the chances of her
being hanging did I lose somebody and
they came back I think uh driving I
think
um then the chances of her being happy
in a marriage is quite high it's 80
percent uh that number drops to 53 after
one partner and go down to five and it's
like less than 30 percent and it just
keeps getting worse from there so
um I mean women that have been with a
lot of guys are undesirable mothers for
your children there's no way around that
that's that there's no data that
suggests that a woman that's been with a
hundred dudes and lost her virginity at
14 is a better choice than a woman
that's a virgin or was with one guy
through her entire early 20s didn't
party and you meet her and your guide
number two sort of thing like the lower
the notch count the better and that's
just the reality of this and you know
you can kick and fight and scream and
want to punch him off in the face
because he says something you don't like
doesn't change the fact like if you have
a problem with the facts the problem
isn't with the facts
too right like take it we can take it
one step further like people can say oh
well we don't know why how that's so
it's it's one of these things where if
we can we can talk about and get into
the brain chemistry of what happens when
two people have sex we know that there's
a dopamine head we know that it's higher
in women than it is in men and it's just
like anything else when you're exposed
to a stimulus over time you need more of
that stimulus to have that same effect
it's the same that's true it's true for
men too I've read the same reason people
build up alcohol tolerances drug
tolerances tolerances to stimulants like
caffeine so this idea that you know I
get so shamed for and get so challenged
on is when I say the more people and
generally women because again we know
that it's a heavier hit of dopamine that
diminishing returns over time so you're
never going to have as
heavy or explosive as those brain
chemicals that dopamine and serotonin
hit when you have sex with somebody as
the first time you ever do it and it's
true for both like again I'm not saying
it's just women just men but what we can
infer is that the more sexual partners
you have the less don't mean you're
going to hit or that's going to hit
which are pair bonding chemicals so when
we talk about stimulus and we can and
somebody challenged me on this last
night where I said it's just like
anything else and they go well well
maybe it's no it's the one thing that's
different it's why would we think that
on generally accepted scientific
principles of stimuli that this is the
one exception and because it fits the
feminine narrative that's the only
reason why it would be I'm going to pose
this question it would be accepted a lot
more if if the research data said that
both men and women suffer the same
consequences for promise promiscuity but
it doesn't it's it's just research data
on women men don't suffer the same way
that women do sorry go ahead Jared yeah
so the question is for this thing like
you put the study up and I mentioned
this on my show at the Buddy yesterday
is there going to become a time we're
like all right we don't we don't need to
look at the studies and and need some
academic or someone with a PhD behind
their name to say okay this is true and
this is not true when it's something we
all know this is very obvious if you
needed to see it you inherently knows a
man like 500 years ago they knew if a
woman was promiscuous she was a bad
choice for what yeah nothing against cop
but people do that with my stuff like oh
where'd you get that information what's
the study I was like I have two eyes and
a brain I can look outside and [__]
see it in front of my eyes do you not
know that a virgin wife is better than a
Street walking prostitute do you really
have that confusion in your head and if
so like good luck to you buddy you're
gonna have a rough ride in this life um
but moth brings it up on his show all
the time like where's the studies
where's the facts where's the data like
dude look how do you not know this for
you
this world today though right like a lot
of women are all like I'm just speaking
my truth and all that means is what a
woman says I'm just speaking my truth it
just means that she's believed the lies
that she's told herself that's what it
means whatever I feel is true yeah or
whatever I feel right now is true based
on what's true you can't be wrong
because they're just stealing so they
must be true yeah
a joke
yeah this is a major red flag and I used
to have this with one of the chicks that
I had the most turmoil with
and she would say exactly this like I'm
doing this because this is what I feel
that I should be doing right
and every single time a woman uses that
excuse to justify horrible Behavior or
some zodiac sign
she needs to be
really fast yeah like it's I mean it's a
conversation you can have I mean if
you're vetting women I mean if you're
spinning plates you're looking to have
kids or something like that it's a
conversation I would have is you know
like how do you feel about horoscopes
how do you feel about energy crystals
you know like how do you feel about you
know female promiscuity or or studies
that say you know this about female
promise Beauty see what they do and if
they start losing their [__] or they
start fighting against it or they're
like well I just feel like because I'm
in Aries I should only be without
whatever then I mean look if you can't
lead a woman I'm going to tell you this
straight up guys this is going to be
like I have to do an update in my uh
book so there's going to be a first
edition update so I'm going to update
some of the red flags and one of the red
flags that I need to add is look
if you can't lead a chick then you're
going to have a miserable life you know
she's just gonna constantly you know
push her butt and [__] test you it's
just gonna be a pain in the ass right
um women need to be led in that sense
and if they're not going to fall into
your frame and that's fine look you know
you want to be basic you want to be beta
you want to comply you want a happy wife
happy life you want to bend the knee you
want to do chore play and wash all the
dishes and maybe get starfish sex once a
month cool have you know have at it like
have fun with that right
you do you
the horoscope girls are fun because you
can guys ask me that all the time too
into astrology is like every girl's into
some woo-woo stuff just tell her like
you kind of like you're not into it but
you understand that it could be true and
then start making [__] up and be like
make up horoscopes I had to grow once
the crystal she's like oh don't touch it
you're gonna like clog the crystals and
and I touched it I was like watch it'll
shine brighter tomorrow because I'm like
a positive energy source and she woke up
she's like oh my God whoa whoa whoa It's
like playing with children like my
three-year-old niece like they can live
in this fantasy world and you just make
it up you're like all right you're a
princess and I'm a bad guy and like I'm
gonna come and try to steal your brother
my nephew from the castle and then you
guys have to like fight me like okay and
then okay act scene ready go and then
like you can do that with your chicks
too especially those like the woo-woo
energy type chicks it's really fun I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below and the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out